In January, we did a segment about a focus
group that pollster and researcher Frank Luntz
did with Trumpet's about their media consumption
and how they end up believing things about
the election.
And what we found out was not particularly
surprising.
A lot of Fox News, a lot of Newsmax, a lot
of OEI, and it was very eye opening.
Frank Luntz did another great focus group
a few days ago with anti vaccine trumpet's.
These are trumpet's who are has its.
And to get the coronavirus vaccine and we're
going to look at some clips here, but the
big takeaway is that our suspicions about
anti vaccine Republicans and Trampas appear
to basically be correct, which is that a full
year.
Of disinformation from Trump, downplaying
the pandemic, downplaying its severity.
That's a big part of why Trump and Republicans
now in great proportion, do not plan to get
the coronavirus vaccine.
So let's get right into it with the first
clip, then we'll talk about it when I say
covid-19 vaccination vaccine.
Adam, what do you think of first?
A miracle, albeit suspicious.
Lauren, I'm sure too many questions.
Patrick Rush from California, experimental
Aaron.
Impressive, but hesitant.
Marie Gary, not knowing the long term side
effects.
Jan.
Long term side effects unknown, Matthew, experimental
and unknown, how will affect long term?
David from Texas.
Long term side effects, I am from I unproven,
Lisa.
Efficacy and so these responses about the
vaccine range from the suspicious to the completely
debunked talking points, for example, unproven
and efficacy unknown, for example, it's quite
the opposite.
The Phase three trials of these vaccines approved
that these are some of the most effective
vaccines ever developed by humans or by anybody.
I don't know how many vaccines have been developed
by animals, but these are some of the most
successful vaccines and effective ones ever
developed.
Huge efficacy at preventing symptomatic illness,
period, and almost perfect at preventing serious
illness.
We know that that's not an unknown quantity.
They just don't know.
Rushed.
We've gone over this many times, the MRSA
platform, underdevelopment for decades specifically,
so that when you have a need for a specific
vaccine, it's a faster process.
It wasn't rushed.
This is how long it takes to develop MRSA
vaccines, possible long term side effects.
You can always say that about any vaccine
at any time.
The polio vaccine was developed in nineteen
fifty five.
That's sixty six years ago.
One could say, how do we know side effects
don't start at the sixty seven year mark.
What we know about vaccines and how they work.
This idea of some future effect is not a concern
based on all of the best medical science.
So then they get into where do these ideas
come from?
It's remarkable, but it's also pretty predictable.
Oh, Frank, can I just say that it's all very
logical.
Like I look at this logically, there's no
craziness, because I think one way politically
that I can't look at logic and reason.
And I think what you said very kind of cavalierly
about so what?
That the pharmaceuticals let the results out
five days after the election.
And to me, that's a big.
So what?
It just it makes you doubt a little bit of
the motives and the politicization of science.
So if you really want us to trust the science,
I think politics has to be taken out of it.
Mm hmm.
And also, if we could be if we could be told
that by being vaccinated, things would get
back to normal again and they don't even know
when that happened and that happened.
But that's not happening now.
We're still mass.
Don't get together with family and said the
other night, oh, you could have a small gathering
by 4th of July gathering, maybe waiting if
we behave.
Yes, we were people and a few hotdogs.
I mean, that's me.
If everyone's getting vaccinated, we got to
move on.
And what you just saw was what happens when
politics gets put in the middle of this?
It's just got to come out somehow.
I think that that is going to be key to all
of this.
That and ask yourself ask yourself who put
the politics there, which side had a benefit
to having politics introduced to this, and
now they just keep it going.
It's not going to be taken out.
Now, that last comment is interesting.
Who had an interest in injecting politics
into this?
One of the focus group participants said the
injection of politics for personal benefit
on this pandemic in the United States was
Trump and Republicans.
Democrats had no interest in this case in
injecting politics.
Democrats just wanted to say, let's do what
the doctors say.
Let's do it.
The public health experts say Trump calculated,
if I downplay this, if I disagree with the
public health experts, it'll go away and that's
best for me.
It's better for me politically not to take
this seriously, at least publicly.
And if it hadn't been that serious, Donald
Trump would have been easily reelected.
I've said that before.
If Trump handled the virus well, he also would
have been reelected.
But the global handling of the virus actually
tells us that the best political strategy
is the same as the best medical strategy.
You step aside and you listen to doctors.
New Zealand did it.
Australia did it.
Taiwan did it.
Rwanda did it.
There's other countries as well.
The leaders where I mean, OK, Paul Kagame
in Rwanda didn't need to do well.
That's a different situation.
But you look at New Zealand and other other
places, when they did well with the virus,
they did well politically.
And the best way to deal well with the virus
was just to do what the doctor said.
But these folks believe that it's Democrats
who injected politics.
Trump made a political call, not a medical
call, to say 15 cases will soon be zero.
He privately knew how much more serious it
was, but he continued to downplay it publicly.
It was Trump who initially injected politics.
Let's continue.
It's not right, OK?
The fear mongering started at the beginning
and it's never ended.
Right.
And if there was a point that I want to see,
I want to see the data point that says when
we reach herd immunity and what percentage
is there a percentage of the population that
could be vaccinated?
And then we're herd immunity because I the
that the minute they tell you that the goalposts
will move again.
Right.
Because it was how many days until we're done
and we can take off our masks in three weeks
until if we all do this and it'll be over
and we're tired of that, they set it up and
then it moves.
And so how do you trust that if we all get
to vaccination level, we're going to be done
with this?
And don't forget who changed the definition
of herd immunity from natural to vaccinated.
So talk about what?
Politicizing science, fear mongering.
Nearly 600000 dead officially, probably seven
hundred and fifty thousand dead if you include
unreported or unofficial covid deaths.
What's funny about saying we don't trust anything
now because we were told this would be over
in three weeks.
Those were the political statements Trump
made in twenty twenty.
Think about the lack of logic there.
They don't trust Biden now.
They don't trust the vaccine now.
They don't trust the government now because
Trump said it'll be over by Easter of twenty
twenty when obviously it wasn't going to be
over by Easter of twenty twenty.
They don't seem to realize that their current
mistrust of Biden, who is being honest now
about here's what's going well, but it could
get worse.
And if this isn't going so well, I'm going
to tell you that distrust of Biden is based
on things Trump told them that were wrong.
Now this next clip is very interesting.
I've guessed that even anti vaccine trumpet's,
once they see there are going to be businesses
that say we will require a vaccine maybe to
fly with us, maybe to go to a concert that
we organize, whatever, that's going to get
more people wanting the vaccine.
A bunch of the trumpets in the focus group
do say travel requirements, for example, would
push me to get a vaccine.
Not all of them, but some.
Take a look.
I'm not going to let you board a plane without
having a passport, a digital passport that
says that you got the covid-19 vaccine.
If that were the case, how many of you in
this on this group, how many of you would
get the vaccine if you knew that you could
not get on a plane?
OK, so Debbie would.
I would delay it as long as possible.
I would I wouldn't rush to death, I would
just I would change my travel plans.
OK, Lauren, you would do it.
I love to travel.
I've been you know, we haven't traveled.
I'm used to going away three, four times a
year.
So if I if this is the only way I could go
away, I'm going to go up.
And Jen Jen from Iowa, you get the vaccine.
If it meant that you could travel by flight.
I think eventually I would cave and I would
get the vaccine, even though, like my husband
and I both survive covid last month, he almost
died.
But I still think that at some point I might
be forced to do it and that I would rather
it be my choice than it be forced upon me
by other entities.
Debbie, if it meant you not being able to
fly or you being able to fly, you would get
the vaccine.
I would get the vaccine.
I absolutely love to travel and we love to
take cruises.
And so I would I would I would get it to travel.
So as you can see, some of them say, no, no,
even to travel, I'm not getting a vaccine.
But some of them say no, I really like to
travel.
I'd probably get vaccinated if I needed to.
A reluctant vaccinated person is still vaccinated
and that's that that that's still, I think,
the way the focus should remain.
One other moment.
That's interesting.
Frank Luntz brought in Dr. Tom Frieden, who's
a former CDC director, and Tom Frieden gave
the focus group participants five facts about
vaccines.
It actually changed a lot of minds.
Dr. Frieden, I'm going to go to you now because
Doug says he wants facts.
Let's go get the facts and let's see if you
can move on right now.
One, if you get infected with the virus, it
will go all over your body and stay there
for at least a week and be much more likely
to cause you long term problems than the vaccine
to if you get the vaccine, it will prime your
immune system.
But then the vaccine is gone.
It will not be with you anymore.
Three more than ninety five percent of the
doctors who have been offered this vaccine
have gotten it as soon as they can.
For the more we vaccinate, the faster we can
get back to growing our economy and getting
jobs, and five, if people get vaccinated,
we're going to save at least a hundred thousand
lives of Americans who would otherwise be
killed by covid.
OK.
I want to show of hands.
How many of you would say that those five
facts are impacting you?
Raise your hands.
That their impactful.
Yeah.
Wow.
Wow, that's amazing.
So most people raise their hands there.
So the upside is not all is lost.
Vaccination is continuing to accelerate.
We are now officially averaging two point
five million doses per day.
Hopefully going to three will have a full
report on that tomorrow.
But enough of these folks are suffering the
effects of such aggressive disinformation
and confusion and partizanship that mathematically
we're probably still up against a pretty difficult
situation in terms of getting to herd immunity
on a national level in areas with less vaccine
hesitancy.
It does seem like herd immunity is going to
be achievable.
But we're going to have to hope that travel
restrictions or whatever do push more of these
folks to ultimately get the vaccine.
We'll have more on this on The David Pakman
Show Instagram.
Find us there at David Pakman show